okay
um let's see i'm gonna get uh get
started here just a brief introduction
my name is jason biggs
i am a developer for uh
for the wolfram language uh chemistry
offerings
and i'm here to uh to talk about uh
the latest uh offerings for uh uh
wolfman language chemistry coming out in
version 12.2
um yeah and now is when i hit the stop
video
and uh we just look at the screen
um let's see so the the title of the
talk this year is molecule fingerprints
and visualization
um this is because uh i felt that i
should not use the same talk that i
uh use every single year new
developments and wolfram language
chemistry so i've
added that here as a talk subtitle
and also my manager told me
either always include the abstract on
the front
first page or don't include the abstract
on the first page i couldn't remember
so i've included an iconized version of
the abstract here on the first page um
because i like to be funny uh let's see
so this is the outline
slide um first i will do a brief a very
brief
history of chemistry in the in the
wolfram language
that involves going from chemical data
to entity value to a molecule
there will be a brief look to the future
we have a new data structure available
in version
12.2 and we will look briefly at the
biosequence
then we'll talk about molecule
fingerprints which
i've spent a good amount of time
working on but it's not fully
ready for release in version 12.2 so
this is this is going to be
mainly a sneak peek of features to come
then we will take a brief tour
of some of the resource functions
available that
for a visualization of of molecules
and then we'll finish by looking at the
interactive molecule editor that
is available in version 12.2
titled molecule draw
so let's first look here
at uh the brief history of chemistry in
the wolfram language
so essentially in version 6 we got
chemical data we got chemical data we
got element data isotope data
there are all of these uh these new
functions to give
access to curated data to and by curated
data i mean
this is experimental data that's
available
from sources like nist or pubchem kim
spider
or publications put out by the
by the acs so you can
there are certain entities in it you can
ask for example for the combustion heat
for henry law constants for van der
waals constants
these are all uh experimental
values that are not computable directly
so they need to be
that's what uh that's what we mean by
curated and so
that was in version six then in version
10 we introduced
entities and this provides more unified
interface to the
to the knowledge base so so we as i
mentioned we had chemical data element
data isotope data
well the number of different types of
entities the number of
uh xxx data functions would would
increase
exponentially but in instead we we
introduced
entity value so rather than just simply
the
string uh representing the chemical we
now have these
we call them the yellow boxes right so
this is underneath when you when you
look at this is entity
chemical diphenyl methane and so it
is a an object that represents
this uh this entity in our database and
you can access
money many of the same let's see so all
of the same properties you could in
chemical data plus many more
and there's a nice uh a much nicer
interface for accessing data on multiple
prop multiple entities
multiple properties and different ways
of
presenting the data
then came version 12 where we introduced
the molecule
so the difference between a molecule and
a chemical entity
is that for a molecule you're not
relying on any database call you're not
relying
on there already being an entity in the
knowledge base
so this entity doesn't need to be in
chemical data it doesn't need to be it
doesn't need to be in pubchem you could
have made it up you could have been the
first one
to ever think of this molecule and you
write out its
uh iupac name and molecule will create a
data structure from that
and then you can visualize generate 2d
or 3d coordinates
and compute properties for it this was
introduced in version 12.
and if you like if you're curious very
curious among the uh
the audience you can see the entire
design process
uh because that is something that uh
that we've started doing so it's uh
so actually if you look at for the the
very second episode of live ceoing
you'll find it was about uh chemistry
and we were deciding do we want
do we want to do this as an entity or as
a
as a function and we did we decided we
wanted to do it as a function
and so that's how molecule came about
and if you're ever curious
about some of the decisions that were
made i recommend
going to the tape so
um but now in version 12.2
we introduce the the biosequence and
this is not my area of expertise this is
developed
in-house by by john casler a resident
expert
on bioinformatics so
i highly recommend this presentation
from the last year's tech conference
representing biological sequence data in
wolfram language
so using a biosequence you can
you can create an object that represents
a particular dna sequence for example
you can convert that sequence into a
peptide sequence by
translating it or into to an rna
sequence by transcribing it
you can then take that peptide that you
create
and convert it into a molecule if you
like
it turns out to be rather large and you
can actually
generate 3d coordinates and view it this
becomes
of course this is a relatively small
protein with only 197 atoms
so the act of generating 3d coordinates
and
and plotting them becomes uh more
difficult the more atoms that you have
obviously
let's see so so that is biosequence i
highly recommend it
it's uh available in 12.2 with a host
of support functions
so now i'd like to talk briefly about a
slightly esoteric
topic that uh that i've become
interested in over the past year and so
so we have this new uh functionality
that's not quite ready for this
system context and so it's probably
hopefully will come out in the next
version but this is a sneak peek of the
things that are
to come so the basic idea behind a
molecule fingerprint is to take a
molecule
and convert it to a sequence of ones and
zeros
otherwise known as a bit vector
depending on the presence of certain
chemical features
also alternatively you can make a count
vector
keeping track of how many times those
features are present in the molecule
so that's step one to convert to create
a molecule into
a fingerprint step two would then be to
to use various different distance
measures to
give an idea of the molecule similarity
how uh how similar are two molecules
so the basic idea is that molecules that
share
chemical features are more similar than
molecules that don't
and so the uh the more alike
two fingerprints are the the the more
similar the molecules are going to be
of course different types of chemical
features lead to different
types of similarity and as a result in
the
literature and in common use nowadays
there are many different types of
fingerprints available
so the basic functionality
the the basic idea here is that you
would have a
fingerprint function which would return
an operator
that could then be applied onto a
molecule to generate a fingerprint
why does it need to be so convoluted
because there are many different options
available so if we look at the input
form
of that we see so
it's an rd kit fingerprint it returns a
bit vector
it's got various options the the minimum
path length the max path lengths whether
to include
hydrogens whether to include branched
paths
how large do you actually do you want
the resulting bit vector to be
whether to use bit bond types when
generating the
the bits and these are all um
uh vary from different type of
fingerprint to
so the so the different options um
there there are many different options
for every type of fingerprint and so
wrapping it all up into one interface
here
is is quite handy but it means that you
first have to generate a fingerprint
function
and then apply it onto a molecule to get
your fingerprint
so another function will be molecule
fingerprint similarity
so that would take two molecules as an
input and return a numerical
value to represent how similar the
molecules are
zero being completely no overlap
whatsoever and
one being saying they're basically the
same molecule
molecule fingerprint similarity would
take options
such as a fingerprint function and a
distance
measure so another function will be
molecule
nearest where you take a list of
molecules
and a query molecule and then you return
either the
the molecule that is most like the query
or the n molecules that are most like
the query
so it's it works very similar to nearest
except it uses uh
the fingerprint similarity as the the
main distance function
so so a basic the most basic type of
thing
of fingerprints would be substructure
fingerprints
so these are where you generate a set of
substructure
keys and then this predefined set of
keys
you enumerate it and then you you
you set bits or counts in the
fingerprint based on
on whether that feature is present so
the most
the most the most simple feature set you
can imagine
is elements so we know that
water contains oxygen so i can say
molecule contains two
q molecule of water oxygen true
but it doesn't have sulfur so
with that in mind we can define a set of
common
elements and
uh in general you could this is quite
this would be quite easy to do with all
of the elements so you can do
element data open close and generate all
of them
but we don't need to do that because
this is just a simple example so that we
can actually look at the fingerprints
so we set these common elements we
define a molecule
let's see let's make sure these are
evaluated
and then and then we could generate this
fingerprint ourself this boolean vector
by just asking
does the molecule contain that element
and then looping over them and we get a
a vector of true false back
we can look at another molecule and ask
the same question and we can get
two different uh fingerprints so these
lists of true and false
that given the two boolean vectors we
then compute their similarity
in uh for molecule fingerprints people
often use the what's called the the
tanimoto similarity
which is equivalent to the uh to one
minus
the jack jacquard dissimilarity which is
a
built-in wolfram language function so
using this
uh simple fingerprint with these common
elephants
elements uh we can say that these
molecules are
zero point or 75 percent similar
so to make this uh um so that
was uh if we were to just do that using
existing functions but we
the um the whole idea here is to create
a simple
and efficient api for generating these
functions
so we create a fingerprint function
based on substructures and we give the
substructure patterns being the
common elements we generate the
fingerprint function
then we apply that onto a list of two
molecules
and it returns to bit vector data
structures
and if you like you can look at the the
documentation this is a data structure
so those were
these were introduced in 12.1 these have
various uh
operations they're mutable
and yeah they're fully documented
so let's see there we go um you can
you apply those uh to fingerprints you
can then visualize them
and let's see does this well
so those don't exactly scale here um
let's see so so this the ones and zeros
tells you whether those uh those
features
are present or not present
and so then if we want if we wanted to
compute the similarity from these
fingerprints we would take we would find
first the um the total number of bits
between the two uh fingerprints and then
the the total number of bits
in common so this is uh the bits that
are set in both fingerprint one and two
and this is the total number of bits and
when we compute that we get the same
value for the similarity
as we did using the the built-in jaccard
dissimilarity
or we can for efficiency's sake we can
feed both molecules to molecule
fingerprint similarity
and give the given uh fingerprint
function
so we've already defined this and this
is the the substructure fingerprint that
uses that list of common elements
and it returns the value of 0.75
so one more step would be to ask
not just whether a given feature is
present in a molecule but how
how often does it occur in the molecule
so we can take those common elements
and we can apply that to a molecule and
count them and so
this for this toy example it essentially
reproduces the chemical formula
we uh we see there are three hydrogen
atoms six carbon atoms two oxygen atoms
etc
or we can create a fingerprint function
until we
instead of a bit vector we want a count
vector
and we apply that to the two molecules
and we receive
uh this back so this is another form of
a fingerprint this is what
so this is a count vector
and so with a count vector we can't use
the built-in jacquard dissimilarity
we instead use the the resource function
multi-set jacquard dissimilarity
which takes into account not just
whether
a certain feature is present but how
often it is present
so when you when you compute the number
of bits in common
for the previous uh computation it takes
into account
how many of those bits are there in each
of the molecules
and so we can use uh the multi-set
jacquard dissimilarity
and we can get a value and we see
they're they're less these two molecules
are less similar now that we take counts
into a
account and as before we can just
we can cut all of that out and call
molecule fingerprint similarity directly
and give it the the fingerprint function
which is now defined to use count
vectors instead of bit vectors
so uh we can take that a little bit
farther by uh um using a more
sophisticated set of patterns
so in this case we've we've got a list
of 300 predefined
functional groups and these functional
groups have a name
and they have a given pattern so this
this is this is what's called a molecule
pattern and it describes
a carbon with four bonds to it
and three of those are hydrogens and it
is ba
bonded to another carbon atom about
which we specify much
uh much less so that's that's the
definition
uh in a pattern of a primary carbon atom
same with secondary
tertiary carbon um and on the way down
so if we look at a given molecule and
ask which of those patterns are present
we see it might have it's got primary
alcohol
rotatable bonds uh certain uh certain
keys for
toddler for what being tautomerizable
so let's see so if we define that so
then you can uh
if you like you can look to see whether
the where these uh
these substructures occur in the
molecule
i think it's fairly neat there so now
now that we have that list of
substructures defined
we can define a fingerprint function
based off of those
and we can get back a count vector from
it and it will tell us exactly how
many times we see those those features
in the molecule
and so that is uh would then be you fed
to the same
similarity functions as before
another so what we've seen so far are
some substructure key fingerprints where
you have a predefined set of
substructures
but more commonly used nowadays are
hash based fingerprints where the number
of subs
possible substructures is incredibly
large
and so therefore there is no attempt
made to enumerate all the substructures
beforehand
instead you generate the substructures
at the time of looking at a molecule
and then you use a a deterministic hash
function to take the substructure and
convert it into
an integer and that integer tells you
what bit
you are setting and then if desired you
can take that uh
that bit and fold it down to get a
number
uh between commonly between 1 and
2048 or some other multiple of
of eight this so it results in a smaller
fingerprint
faster similarity comparison but it can
also result in bit collision where two
different substructures end up setting
the same bit
so it has its drawbacks
so this is a common type of
this hash based fingerprint so the
substructure here
is an atom pair so look so here we have
two
oxygen atoms with uh with a single with
a vertex degree of one
and they're separated by four bonds
and so that in it of itself is a
substructure
here we have two oxygen atoms each with
a
with a heavy atom vertex degree of one
and separated by seven atoms
seven bonds and so that is another type
of substructure and so when you
apply this type of algorithm onto a
molecule
and generate all of the different atom
pairs within that molecule
it's the common practice is to then take
those atom pairs those substructures and
hash those to a 64-bit integer
and then those are used as the keys
in the count vector it's also possible
to
uh to to get to use this in a bit vector
form where you
you ignore the count information
so right
so another type of common substructure
is to use path-based fingerprints this
this is a type of substructure that was
uh popularized by the daylight company
and so here you generate what you do is
when you look at a molecule
generate all paths of with a given
length and oftentimes that
is a range so for the
for the rdkit fingerprint function
it will generate all paths
between uh with a length between length
of one or
seven and then from those
take those paths look at all the atoms
in the paths
and uh atom properties and bond
properties
and combine all that together to
generate a
hash that is then folded down to a bit
between 1 and 2048 and you set that bit
and when you do that it might set
these mint bits
alternatively if you set the the min
path length instead of
one to four you set fewer bits
circular fingerprints are a similar kind
of thing where you uh
gen rather than all paths you look at
all
uh all substructures where atoms are a
given
length a given a topological distance
from a particular atom
but it's the same type of uh
action where you generate
algorithmically generate all
possible substructures convert take
those substructures
convert it to a hash and then set that
bit
so we can wrap this all up into a
molecule nearest
function and i won't bother to evaluate
this it's it's fairly speedy but i don't
we are running short on time essentially
you can um
in this example here we take a list of
uh
2000 molecules taken from curated from
pubchem by bob nakbar and we uh convert
those to molecules
and then we take a query molecule
and we try to find the uh the the most
similar molecule
to it and so this example just shows
that based on the different types of
fingerprints you can get very different
answers to what is the nearest
molecule
to the query so now
i think it is time that i should skip
on a head to um
molecule draw because it is the new
feature
and uh it's fairly neat i think
um so the idea here is that you can
interactively create and edit molecules
um and so you can add
modify bonds it's
it's it's we need more features so
hopefully more features will be to come
but essentially
so we start here with an empty palette i
select a single bond
i got it in there i start adding more
bonds
now i can just come in and close the
loop
if i don't like the way that it end up
looking i redraw it
i can change one of those atoms to an
oxygen
and then i can put a chlorine on that
oxygen and it should complain to me
it did it highlights it in red because
oxygen doesn't like having
three bonds unless of course it has a
positive charge so we add the charge and
everything seems fine
and now we return that and we have a
molecule
we could also do this on existing
molecules so
first we we use the charact optical
recognition we
recognize this as a molecule and then we
draw it
right and so we can go in here and start
uh
adding uh adding atoms
and then
so that
it didn't that didn't quite work so i'm
going to need to figure out what
happened there so i can undo the things
that i've done or i can redo them
and that is essentially the way the uh
the editor works here i can delete
i can delete bonds yeah
and so i think at 9 58
is a good time to uh stop
the talk and move to the um
let's see future directions i want to i
want to
to mention this um we are looking
uh at what to do next right new data
structures what
uh enhancements to 2d and 3d plots we
want to
add labels to to plots uh
add a custom r group labeling custom
styling we're interested in looking at
chemical reactions or macromolecules
having tighter connections to external
sources these are all things that uh
that
that are um that we are looking at
and if we welcome any feedback to help
us uh prioritize that
so now i tab over to see if anybody
has asked any questions
but other than that i think that um
that is the uh
the talk ah so um
let's see so when we when you create a
3d structure right so
so all you're starting just from the
from the
graph the chemical graph you know you
know what the connectivity is
of the the protein generating the 3d
structure for that is a very non-trivial
task
we use a distance matrix a distance
geometry method
which attempts to to use some uh
some real world information to generate
a random
uh structure which is then um
what is uh then minimized uh using the
mmf
uh force field um and uh yes i will
upload the notebook here as soon as the
talk is over i think
and with that i think the the time is
over
thank you very much